i'm so honored to say that camden and
colton are joining us right now
hi guys
hey it's a pleasure to meet you
camden it's such an honor to meet you
i love your story
what was it
camden that
was there sort of the aha moment was
there an origin story or a spark to the
flame what was it that got you started
yeah so at the height of the pandemic um
we me and my brother were sitting and
watching tv and there was all these news
reports that were popping up and it was
anxiety provoking seeing these families
me and my brother were really compelled
to help and make a difference and our
families or our family always instilled
in us to
help other people and put people before
you put yourself and it was
that at that moment that we knew kind of
that we needed to do something
so colton what do you do in that moment
you look to each other
you feel that you know feeling
then what
well i think our first step was just
like talking to our parents because i
don't know they have a great influence
on us and uh
yeah i don't know that was just our
first step talking to our parents and
just talking about how to get the word
out there and how to get people to help
us too uh i think your parents must have
been so proud of you in that moment if
i mean
i have two daughters
and
anytime they come to me on their own
wanting to do something of service or
for someone else or a thought that's
beyond themselves
i am just so relieved and excited
and i'm amazed that your parents were
able to like leap into action the way
they did um like explain what beyond the
crisis means
so beyond the crisis really has to do
with kind of going beyond the crisis
because
we all know about the current pandemic
and
like what that caused for a lot of
people and how that was such a huge
issue but food insecurity is an everyday
problem it's an ongoing problem and we
really wanted to address that
on top of kind of
the exacerbated effects caused by the
pandemic so it was really that that kind
of pushed us to get started get working
i mean you guys are so amazing really
every word you're saying i'm just
hanging on it
and
you have helped over
a thousand
families
a thousand yes
i mean that is just an incredible feat
and some have actually called you
personally to say thank you
did that happen yeah yeah so
my actually there was a lady that showed
up in our driveway
and she had an apple tree and she
reached out to us via email and she even
was so kind of compelled and inspired by
her story that she showed up on her
doorstep with all of these apples and it
was just a really heartwarming moment
for my brother and i oh what a poetic
way to know you're on the right path
your life could have looked so different
but this is your story now because of
the steps you've taken
and we're so amazed by what you're doing
and then our friends at lundberg family
farms are donating ten thousand dollars
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i mean this is how you're inspiring
people
let alone companies who are watching you
going
we want to be a part of that
it's so beautiful what you are
compelling everybody to do and we want
to make sure that you go to our website
at thedrewberryshow.com because maybe
you have something that you want to
contribute to camden and colton i know i
certainly hear it
[Applause]
may i ask um as a last question
um i always like to learn from people
who are about action and not just words
may i ask a piece of advice camden yes
on how i can better serve my community i
actually actually say all right great i
was just i was gonna say that like i'm
13 and my brother's 18 so i think it's
just like it's kind of inspiring that
like you can be any age
like you don't have to have like you
have to be oh no you don't you don't
have to be 40 and 50 to make a
difference we really
wanted to instill in other teenagers
that just by taking a few steps and like
moving forward that you can make a huge
difference and that's why i'm here today
[Applause]
and colton
like
the name you give to a 13 year old human
is one of the most beautiful i've ever
seen
so truly thank you for being you
and your age is just even more amazing
because you're right it is an ageless
thing to take care of others you could
be older or younger and anything in
between and i think that's a very
valuable lesson and we want takeaways in
this world we want to be inspired and
then know how we can do it so your
advice is at any age you can do this
thank you that's perfect
perfect perfect
camden and colton thank you so much and
thank you to our friends at lundberg
farm thank you it means so much to our
show that you would help us do this
[Music]
you